hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and I wanted to spend
a few videos talking about some common
in games that you'll see I know we have
a lot of people to watch the videos some
are very good some are just beginning so
I wanted to take a minute to go over
some of the beginner in games a lot of
people are familiar with but some may
not be so today we're going to be
talking about the king and queen in game
and a lot of times it's going to derive
from just a king and pawn and game
obviously when you promote your pawn to
a queen it becomes a king and queen in
game so want to take a look at just the
easiest way I think to always remember
how to checkmate with a king and a queen
so we'll go ahead and get into it
your key concept if you always want to
think of is you just want to always
limit the spaces that your opponent's
king can go and then you just want to
gradually move down the board limiting
the spaces he can move and then from
there it's going to be easy win so we'll
go ahead and take a look at what that is
going to look like on the chessboard
from here it's blacks move and he's
going to move his King to e4 and we're
going to bring our Queen and we're going
to go ahead and bring it to
b5 and you can already see he can't come
pass this fist rank and so already the
black king is limited to the first four
ranks right here so the black King is
going to move if he ever does move down
one rank as you'll see here let's say
the King moves to e3 and we are simply
going to move our Queen down and here
we'll say Queen to c4 and again we've
already limited this base even more he
can't come past the fourth rank now
because of our queen so we're limiting
to the first three ranks now now if
black decides now to move horizontally
along the third rank we can just chase
him down obviously he can't come past
the e3 square so we can't come over here
because of our queen so he's going to
continue to march down the board we're
going to continue to follow we're going
to continue to follow and now we've
taken his 1 square that he would like to
go to going horizontally now he's going
to be forced to go to the second rank
not as he can't go to h2 because our
Queen so he's going to be forced to go
to g2 and from here just like I said
before we're simply going to bring our
Queen to the third rank and now we're
limiting into the first two ranks now
from here he has a decision he can go
horizontally and do the same thing or he
can go down to the first rank he comes
down to the first rank like we said
before once he comes down a rank we're
going to move our Queen down to the
second rank and we've limited him to the
first rank now obviously he can only
move on the f1 g1 and h1 squares because
of our queen he can't come past this e1
but he is limited to the the 1st rank
here so from here all his only move here
is g1
so when he moves u 1 we continue to
bring our Queen here and now all the
black King can do is just move back and
forth between g1 and h1 we don't want to
move our Queen any farther because it'll
be stalemate but now we can simply leave
our Queen where
is the black king is completely helpless
he's just going to move back and forth
and now we can bring our King into the
action black King is going to move back
and forth we get our King into the mix
and then once our Queen is it excuse me
our King is in the mix we can simply
bring our Queen easy checkmate
so hope you guys enjoy please subscribe
if you haven't already and look out for
more videos in the future thanks for
watching guys